what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
so we are back with injustice yes we are
it has been a little while since we
didn't ingest this video God and justice
- is is amazing I mean it's one of these
stories where it just raises more
questions than it answers now for those
of you guys who are new here to my
channel who are just now joining the
injustice videos on my channel and
justice q the comic book series is
designed to serve as the basis behind
the entire injustice to video game much
like the first injustice comic book
served as a prelude to the first
injustice game this is a freely - the
second game the idea here though is that
we're still getting a kind of bolstering
of things and at this point with regards
to our story we don't really need to
know everything that's going on behind
the scenes just because of the fact this
is only really going to deal with like
Batman Supergirl Blue Beetle Jaime Reyes
and Ted Kord and so on and that's really
going to be about it but the idea here
is that again you if you're if you're
essentially new here in the first part
of injustice q following the events of
the first injustice game the defeat of
Superman so on so forth Lex Luthor had
left a hologram behind following his
death where he spoke directly with
Batman and what he basically said is
there are two options if Batman can
choose Batman can follow this path where
he decides to recreate the world under
his own image which would be horrified
because there'd be a world that was
immersed in fear essentially because
remember Batman is the avatar of fear
that's how he function that's what he
does that's how he tries to keep
criminals in line in the city of Gotham
the other half of this is to reach out
for help and ask other people to assist
in basically rebuilding the world
of course Batman chose to reach out to
other individuals but one of the people
that's chosen here is Ted Kord now what
this does is it transitions over to Ted
Kord proper Wally's training training
Jaime Reyes and that's one of the cool
things here those are the guys who were
new to all this there were really two
blue beetles before Jaime Reyes Jaime
Reyes was a character who was introduced
as part of Infinite Crisis and you'll
actually find those videos down in the
playlist if you want to get yourself
refreshed on who Jaime Reyes is and
about Blue Beetle and you know Ted Kord
and so on but assuming that you don't
want to do all that the long and short
of it is this the Blue Beetle
traditionally derives his powers from a
scarab and the Scarab was actually a
device or kind of this technological
weapon that was created by an alien race
called the reach and what they ended up
doing was basically using the Scarab as
a way to infiltrate other planets and so
they would basically disperse these
scarabs out into the universe and the
Scarab would land on a planet and then
the Scarab would just wait until that
society reached the point
they were technologically advanced and
they were worth conquering and dimma
scarab would activate and bond itself to
a host it would tap into the database of
the reach it would basically begin
reprogramming this personal host and
then turn them into an individual that
can effectively help to bring down that
society from within now there was a
scarab it landed on earth in this kind
of zone history and so on and so forth
but in terms of the Blue Beetle role
that came to a guy by the name of Dan
Garrett and Dan Garrett was just like
this archaeologists that stumbled across
the beetle he was a guy that basically
existed before crisis on Infinite Earths
but eventually Dan Garrett vacated his
role he essentially retired and Ted Kord
picked up the mantle of Blue Beetle the
difference here is that where the beetle
worked for Dan Garrett and it allowed
Dan gear to tap into its powers and so
on Ted Kord couldn't do that
and so in truth ted was really more Blue
Beetle by name only as opposed to
actually having powers now he was still
pretty effective I mean one of the funny
things about his character over the
course of DC's publication history and
even writers would make fun of it with
regards to how it was character with
Hawke and so on if he was like the least
respected superhero ever nobody ever
really gave him any credit but then the
whole events of Infinite Crisis happen
and a villain by the name of Maxwell
Lord shot him in the head which set in
motion the whole idea of the super
heroes banding together and Wonder Woman
killing Maxwell Lord again all that's in
countdown to Infinite Crisis and you'll
find that down in the description
following the death of Ted Kord in the
events of infantry aliy countdown the
Infinite Crisis a kid named Jaime Reyes
you know became the next Blue Beetle and
then you know you had an event called 52
which I believe was 52 which was
basically a year-long series of comics
that dealt with you know Jaime Reyes
learning to become the Blue Beetle and
so again it was really kind of a cool
thing but what this does with regards to
injustice too is it feeds into that
because it's basically Jaime Reyes
learning to become the Blue Beetle now
something to take note of here is this
does not follow perfectly in line with
Jaime Reyes as he existed in DC Comics
and the main line DC stories and the
reason for that is just not really
explained here we don't really know how
Ted Kord met Jaime Reyes all we know is
that they're working together and in
truth this is really just designed to
kind of feed on people's existing
knowledge of Jaime Reyes and Ted Kord as
opposed to create something new so what
does does is it really kind of leads to
the idea that Ted Kord had essentially
backed off he had walked away from the
idea of being Blue Beetle and in her and
Tommy Reyes became the new Blue Beetle
and in his place now of course the other
half of this deals with Batman and
again Batman's going around gathering
resources gathering people who can help
in order to basically rebuild the world
and that's kind of the cool thing here
because this financial incentives the
richest people in the world have all
sorts of money that could be used to
rebuild towns to rebuild streets to help
you know organize society again to
basically restore faith in humanity that
the world can go back to the way it was
before now this is really a little bit
of wishful thinking on behalf of Bruce
Wayne because with something like
injustice taking place Superman the most
idolized and revered superhero among the
entire community in on earth in the DC
landscape becoming a bad guy and trying
to take over the world that forces
humanity to cross this psychological
line that they can't come back from and
so because of that I mean things will
never go back to the way they were
before but things can still be pretty
decent they can still be pretty
reasonable so it's kind of a cool thing
just because of the fact there's a bit
of an argument that takes place here
between Ted Kord and Batman of course
the Ted Kord making the argument Jaime
Reyes is too young he's too
inexperienced
he's not ready to be the Blue Beetle
superhero yet now again this is kind of
cool because this hits home at the idea
of Jason Todd and this is one of the
reasons why a lot of people are saying
that the evil Batman the other Batman
that exists in injustice too is Jason
Todd because the whole idea is that when
Ted Kord and Batman are arguing Ted
kord's basically says you of all people
should know the consequences of sending
a kid that's too young into the
battlefield this hits back ed Jason Todd
Jason Todd of course being one of the
most notable Robins the one who was
killed by the Joker the one who
eventually came back as Red Hood a
vigilante that you know basically tried
to take out crime in Gotham by becoming
part of it and subverting it from within
is it's really kind of a cool story when
it comes to the whole idea of what in
the world is going on with regards to
injustice so it's these small little
goodies these small little tidbits
because remember in injustice one they
did the exact same thing and in justice
one they would drop these little tidbits
drop these little hints and then we'll
all come together and basically answer
the questions that we've been dying to
get the answers to over the course of
the whole story and so ultimately Batman
says look I'm here to see if you are
willing to help to see if you're willing
to pull things together for resources in
order to make the world a better place
of course Ted kord's like yeah man I
guess whatever I'm rich but the idea is
that you know following Batman's
departure Ted Kord is met with the
arrival of Booster Gold now the reason
why this is so important is because
historically speaking in DC Comics
you cannot have Ted Kord Blue Beetle
without Booster Gold
and rightfully so following crisis on
Infinite Earths in 1985 DC dropped off
the idea of the Justice League of
America as we traditionally knew it
which is to say Batman Superman Green
Lantern Wonder Woman flash Aquaman and
so on and they replaced it with a team
called Justice League International and
then eventually that became Justice
League Europe and there's like extreme
justice and so on and so forth but the
idea here is that during this landscape
of these varying Justice League teams
Booster Gold and Blue Beetle basically
became a sort of comedic characters they
had these hilarious moments and they
really provided a lot of comedy in a
story that would have otherwise just
been too drowsy and too serious and so
because of that a lot of fans began to
fall in love with the characters of Blue
Beetle and Booster Gold just because of
how funny they were and so what this
does is basically restore the idea that
not only do they have a long history in
terms of being teammates but they're
extremely close friends and there's
really kind of DC teasing on the idea
that they might even be lovers but the
general idea here is that when it comes
to their characters Booster Gold and
Blue Beetle
they really maintain each other's trust
more so than anything else and so
Booster Gold popping up on the scene and
saying hey I'm going to be there at the
end under normal circumstances would
freak a person out like what do you mean
I'm dying you know but again with
regards to Blue Beetle he's like well I
mean I guess it's my time it was only a
matter of time before it happened and so
again you know it's really kind of Blue
Beetle going on this suit and Booster
Gold making fun of him and that's really
about it
but it's an extremely touching moment
because what is up happening is dark
Batman Suicide Squad breaks in and then
you know cuts off the arm of Blue Beetle
and whisks him away and so what this
does is it leads into the whole idea of
what's going on behind the scenes
who is it that's really running the show
and what we end up doing is we actually
transition to Ra's al Ghul's little
sanctuary thing now the cool thing about
this is that what we find out is that in
addition to Ted Kord Ra's al Ghul is
going around and capturing all these
titans of industry people that deal with
coal mining and people would deal with
you know fossil fuels and natural gas
and all those different things you know
all that kind of good stuff and what we
end up finding out is that in this
injustice universe Ra's al Ghul is very
much rooted in his traditional
appearance and what I mean by that is
Ra's al Ghul is a character that has
really become bigger than his original
intention which is to say Ra's al Ghul
is just
to be this guy that just wants to
dominate the world is how a lot of
people look at it but in truth Ra's al
Ghul is just an extreme environmentalist
that's really all of this there should
be this balance between humans and and
nature itself but when humans become a
problem then the idea is to basically
just reset humanity to wipe it all away
and start from square one
and that's his ultimate goal that's to
basically say look you guys are
literally punishing the earth and so you
guys all lead these different aspects of
society in terms of captains of industry
and so on and so forth and so not only
does he basically destroy all these
buildings that belong to these major
companies killing everybody inside
he in turn has Killer Croc and a villain
named Orca consume all these different
guys one of which is is Ted Kord and so
of course we have this insanely touching
moment between Booster Gold and Ted Kord
when Booster Gold pops up and says look
I tried to make way for the timestream
because remember Booster Gold from the
future he's basically a guy that
travelled into the past as part of a
get-rich-quick scheme but the idea is a
despite his nefarious past he ended up
becoming a pretty you know pretty solid
guy a pretty good guy but the idea is
you can't just manipulate time in DC
Comics you can't just jump around back
and forth through time there's
consequences and there are authorities
that exist I think it's called the time
variance Authority that I'm not going to
swear to that but there are authorities
that exist in order to make sure that
you don't just dance around the
timestream and screw everything up and
so the result is that where Booster Gold
had tried his best to jump back in time
to stop things to keep blue beetle from
dying to keep Ted Kord from dying in the
end he was stopped every single time and
so it's basically inevitable that Ted
Kord is going to die in this particular
circumstance and so again what we do
from here is we basically switch over to
our second story which is called when
you wake up and this is basically the
rise of Supergirl and it's one of the
coolest things because when it comes to
the origin stories of certain characters
they're almost universal right like Kara
zor-el was a pre-crisis on Infinite
Earths character she appeared as part of
a Superman landscape she was created by
Otto bender but her origin story
depicted the idea that she was a
character who was effectively older than
Superman when he was a baby but she was
the daughter of a man by the name of
zor-el by a woman by the name of Elora
and the idea was that she was just kind
of living her life and doing whatever is
it you do on Krypton when you're a kid
going to her Science Academy or schools
or what-have-you but that ultimately
Krypton wants to basically win awry once
the core ruptured and the planet
exploded that she was sent out it's part
of a astro city as
as Superman who was sent out on his
escape pod but the the issue ended up
being that where Superman crash-landed
on earth Kara arrived on earth much much
later and so this created a sort of
discrepancy among their ages in the
sense that where Kara's Oh al was
technically older than Superman by the
time she arrived on earth
she looked much much younger and so
again it was one of those interesting
situations but this origin story is
rooted into that but what it also does
is it gives us a lot of their personal
life in the sense that is basically you
know jor-el and zor-el both of whom are
brothers I just kind of having fun and
do anything now they're not carefree
they're not kind of goofy and wild for
jor-el is clearly more of like the rural
kind of guy and in zor-el is really more
of just like hey let's just go and do
crazy stuff but the idea here is that it
really focuses on the notion of Kara
zor-el knowing where she is
understanding your place but also being
afraid of things they're a little bit
different being afraid of the unknown
and so what is up happening here is of
course you know where she's you know
breaks her arm in the whole experience
and then we pick up six years later we
actually joined the fall of Krypton and
this is basically the idea of Krypton
being totally obliterated by Brainiac
once he detonates the core now remember
Brainiac as a long history in terms of
Krypton in terms of how he's involved
the role that he plays in the
destruction of the planet the idea with
regard select a new 52 for example which
is to say the post 2011 BC landscape is
that you effectively had Brainiac going
around and wiping out planets in order
to stem the flow of another race that it
invaded from a different universe that
origin stories down in the description
it was a little weird but it was still
the idea that Brainiac was the reason
why Krypton had been totally destroyed
but what basically ends up happening
here in this ensuing conflict is that
zor-el is injured and essentially killed
and ultimately it leads to jor-el and
his sister more or less or I guess your
sister-in-law Laura grabbing Kara and
grabbing Superman and then putting them
in pods and sending them out of Krypton
which of course leads to Kara ship being
knocked off course which explains why it
is that she had just been floating out
in space for so long and so where
Superman had arrived on earth relatively
quickly I mean it was still a little bit
of time there but where he had arrived
on earth relatively quickly
ah Kara's RL was just kind of stuck in
stasis she was basically just not really
aging she were just kind of floating out
there and eventually shows up 35 years
later so again this feeds into the
traditional origin of Supergirl in DC's
comics she was older than Superman but
arrived on earth after
man and so she appeared much younger the
difference is that witness being the
injustice universe instead of being met
by the arrival of Superman she's met
with the arrival of Black Adam and
conduct now this is kind of a cool thing
because remember Black Adam ended up
siding with the regime
he ended up siding with Superman the
black Adam is a bit of a wild card
because in the original injustice
stories he sided with Superman for no
other reason than to keep his home
country of conduct safe and that's the
important thing to remember about Black
Adam Black Adam has no allegiances he
doesn't swear allegiance to any one
particular person and under normal
circumstances he kneels to no man he
does whatever it is that he needs to do
in order to keep conduct safe and that's
the nature of his character you can
almost imagine a conversation with him
you know when his answer is I'll do
whatever I have to do if I have to burn
cities to the ground if I have to
destroy the world I'll do whatever it
takes to keep conduct safe the issue
here is that it was Black Adam weighing
his odds in a conflict with the regime
versus siding with the regime and at the
end of the day he sided with the regime
because it's powerful as he is as
capable as he is and even being able to
overpower Shazam in some circumstances
black Adam would not be able to take on
the combined forces of Superman and
Wonder Woman and the flash and the Green
Lantern or I guess the Yellow Lantern
Hal Jordan he wouldn't be able to take
them all on at the same time and keep
conduct safe there would be a loss of
life and conduct itself would inevitably
have been destroyed we saw that in the
first injustice comic and so the result
is that he sided with the regime and
basically took up arms with them now the
reason why this matters is because
following the events of the first
injustice game Black Adam retreated back
to Tom dock and then turned it into
basically a place for people who were
part of the regime and had essentially
disbanded following the defeat of
Superman could take up residence and
find solace so it was really more of
just kind of like a staging ground for
whatever the regime will become later on
down the line and so of course where the
arrival of Supergirl is met with the
arrival of you know surrounding
countries all of whom demand to know
what it is that's in conduct you know
the idea that this particular general
you know from a place called a balaiah
I think is how you pronounce it
ultimately puts his hands on Black Adam
and is made to pay the ultimate price ah
this basically leads to Adam you know
again an indication here that of what
Black Adam is willing to do in his mind
Kara zor-el landed in conduct which
means that she's now a resident of Conda
anybody who steps in and tries to remove
her will pay the ultimate price they'll
be made to understand the error of their
ways and so again
kind of cool because what he basically
tells his people is look if she speaks
if she wakes up and she does anything if
anything happens she indicates she wants
food or whatever the case may be you
come and you tell me immediately and so
of course when Black Adam goes to speak
with with Kara zor-el the idea is she
asked what's going on here and black
Adam begins to sort of recount the
events that took place during the
injustice game but notice this he does
not do it with an honest eye he does not
tell her honestly what it is that's
going on instead he basically says you
know once upon a time there was this
amazing guy named Superman who found the
love of his life and a woman named Lois
Lane and then a mean evil villain named
the Joker took out two the way
everything the Superman loved and
Superman recognized that there are so
many dangerous villains out there that
they have to be kept at bay and so
Superman tried to implement an era of
peace and then the mean evil Batman
tried to stop him it's very much
propaganda but that's the great thing
about injustice because maybe it's not
it all depends on what side that you're
sitting on I mean a man with a family
you know what were the wife and two
children may be willing to bend his knee
to a totalitarian society if it means
his family will stay safe whereas
somebody with no family will say why are
you bending your knee to that guy ah you
need to fight everything off but they
don't have a family to worry about at
the same time a man that does have a
family may look around and say I'm not
okay with my family living under a
totalitarian regime things are okay now
but what about five years from now or a
year from now or 10 years from now
things could be worse off you know it's
not an absolute thing it's just one of
these circumstances where everybody
views things differently and that's the
whole nature of this is because despite
everything that had happened all these
skirmishes all these conflicts between
Batman and Superman the arrival of this
Justice League from an alternate reality
to help defeat Superman from the
injustice universe and his regime there
are still people who swear allegiance to
Superman who still say he was right and
he was doing the right thing that so
ultimately the response of Supergirl is
then we have to go find Superman we have
to go free him we have to get him out
and so again this creates a pretty
dangerous situation because now the
question becomes with regards to Batman
if Superman was more than he could
handle on his own and if it took five
years for Superman to effectively be
defeated then what hope would Batman
have against Superman and Supergirl and
so again it's really kind of crazy plus
this also raises a lot
questions is this going to be a
Supergirl where the kind of power she
had before crisis on Infinite Earths
because Supergirl before crisis on
Infinite Earths was more powerful than
Superman in a lot of ways she was
stronger she was faster you know she was
more durable she fought longer and
harder she was the last superhero
standing when it came to fighting the
anti-monitor she was the only one that
can continue to hold her own everybody
else had effectively been defeated
there's a lot of questions to be
answered when it comes to her character
but the faction aims here that this does
have black Adam basically say conduct
will be your home again hinting to this
idea that individuals who were formerly
part of the regime can now find solace
and conduct as a basically a wait for
the re-emergence of Superman by some
means in order to restore the regime
back to leadership among the planet
Earth but with that being said guys
we're going to go ahead and bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
comment explain make sure you guys hit
the sub button to become part of the
rock or you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and leave a comment
down below let me know what you guys
think about injustice 2 so far because I
absolutely love it it's like injustice 1
where it's a slow build and then it
starts getting to like all these crazy
events of hangars and so on but let me
know what you guys think and I will
catch you all on it
peace
[Music]